I think that there's definitely somebody out there.
Taking a page from the speculative dreams of Carl Sagan,...
...a group of scientists and entrepreneurs are devising a system...
...to take earthly messages deep into space.
And they want you to join in.
Yeah, I think there is something up there.
The Lone Signal Project will be the first continuous transmission from Earth,...
...beamed with a hope there's someone out there to listen.
We should send messages to aliens.
Aimed at Gliese 526, a possible habitable star system about 17.6 light years from Earth,...
...the communications will be blasted from a Jamesburg Earth Station dish in California.
The team has invited everyone to participate with one free text message-sized contribution,...
I hope they realize I'm one of them.
...offering more sizable custom transmissions for a fee.
I mean, really, I'm in love with this one man.
Lone Star will even allow people to track the progress of their messages...
...as they hurdle toward Gliese 526.
Apparently, not everyone is charmed by the open-sourced, extraterrestrial life-seeking mission.
So why not?
A headline in The Verge asked ominously,...
..."Are alien hunting scientists going to trigger a planetary invasion?"
Please don't hurt us.